pour terminer je vous propose de tourner
quelques pages du nouveau roman de
pascal sevran c'est son sixième il
s'agit de la suite sur journal intime à
cri depuis le décès de son ami 6 ans 99
michel vial anne-dominique terme
pour tout le cheptel vendée
le chant font entre paris et morterolles
en deviennent entre les lumières du
music hall et la solitude de l'écrivain
pascal sevran tient depuis six ans un
journal qui a commencé avec la mort d'un
jeune homme son compagnon et qui
s'achèvera avec la sienne
une démarche étrangers terrible destinée
à combler un vide et à magnifier les
minutes charmante de sa vie dont
l'écriture est une manière de régler les
brosses personnel qui vous évite tous
les confessionnaux et tous les
psychanalystes d'autres trouveront
d'autres parades au temps qui passe et
au chagrin moi ce sont les mots et dans
ces mots là en effet stéphane tient
debout et et beaucoup d'autres gens se
retrouvent
il viole d'amour et un croyez qu'en
tétravalent on aime envers il y à 25 ans
avant de faire le merely flore comme il
le dit à la télévision pascal sevran
avait commencé par l'écriture des
chansons déjà et surtout des romans
salué par la critique
le tout empreint d'élégance et de
mélancolie à l'image de son univers
intime
la vie dépasse de très loin
l'imagination est d'ailleurs j'étais
dans tous mes romans et tous les
écrivains sont dans tous leurs romans
même si j'écrivais larron sur la vie
d'une fourmi sont donc quand même
mais voilà la littérature embellie tout
même nos chagrin inconsolable et gai à
la fois pascal sevran c'est rendre
pittoresque les personnages de son petit
théâtre privé pour la plus grande joie
de ses lecteurs qui se cherche aussi
entre les lignes du roman de sa vie
je suis souvent content réjouit émus
bouleversés
voilà heureux faut se garder des grands
mots vous remettant la cravate
malgré le jeu social et médiatique qui
fait partie de son métier public
pascal sevran dans son journal a su
rester sept enfants à bruz
anticonformiste souvent bourbon et
surtout inquiets qui donne du sel à son
écriture tout en sachant sans doute
depuis longtemps que le souvenir de
bonheur ne ressemble pas au bonheur
il veut lui couper ça n'a pas changé la
télévision